on peut déjà commencer par noter les
avancées que représente cet accord 130
pays signataires dont les états unis la
chine la russie la france c'est à dire
une part significative du pib mondial
seuls neuf états ont sans trop de
surprise rejeté l'accord dont l'irlande
la hongrie ou l'estonie qui pratiquent
en europe une fiscalité agressive mais
on peut toujours espérer que ces pays se
joindront au reste de la communauté
internationale d'ici à 2023
alors cet accord et bien elle vise donc
à récupérer une partie des profits
générés par les multinationales et qui
échappe encore aujourd'hui à l'impôt le
texte fixe un taux minimum de 15% ce qui
devrait permettre aux états d'engranger
des gains fiscaux substantiels l'impôt
minimum mondial sur les sociétés avec un
taux minimum d'au moins 15% devrait
générer environ 150 milliards de dollars
de recettes fiscales mondiale
supplémentaires chaque année
sauf que ce taux de 15% il ne règle pas
la question de la concurrence fiscale
entre états et du dumping qui va avec
sur les 130 pays qui ont accepté
l'accord 74 ce qui représente quand même
plus des trois quarts de l'économie
mondiale 74 ont un taux d'imposition des
sociétés supérieure à 15%
un taux qui en plus comme vous pouvez le
voir sur ce graphique n'a fait que
baisser ces deux dernières décennies
d'ailleurs ce taux ne devait pas être
initialement de 15 mais bien de 21%
c'est en tout cas ce qu avait au départ
proposées joe biden selon le tax justice
network une ong de lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale
la première mouture du plan d'imposition
global des sociétés auraient permis de
récupérer non pas 150 milliards de
dollars mais bien 640 milliards
c'est-à-dire plus de quatre fois plus
dont près de 30 milliards pour
l'hexagone beaucoup plus que les 5 à 10
milliards d'euros de recettes annoncées
ce jeudi par le ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire et puis il ya la question
de l'inégalité entre pays riches et
pauvres selon oxfam
ces derniers devrait grappiller que
quelques miettes des recettes fiscales
générées grâce à l'accord non seulement
l'accord laisse encore des failles aux
multinationales pour pratiquer l'évasion
fiscale mais il devrait accentuer les
inégalités entre pays riches et pays
pauvres
un accord juste aurait permis une
meilleure redistribution des droits à
taxer mais 60% des recettes de l'impôt
minimum seront captés par les pays du g7
les pays en développement qui
représentent plus d'un tiers de la
population mondiale ne devrait percevoir
que 3% des recettes
alors oui il s'agit là bien d'un accord
historique oui il renforcera sans
conteste la souveraineté fiscale des
états qui l'ont signé mais n'oublions
pas que le chemin semble encore long
avant d'atteindre l'harmonie fiscal tant
attendu